Let's go to Nathan.
It's been a little while since we heard from
Nathan and seven one seven.
What's going on?
Nathan?
Thank you for taking my call, David.
Um, I was, I was wondering if you are, I'm
sure you definitely heard about Gretta assume
for or against your name and beliefs.
Yes.
It goes it correctly.
That's all real fast.
All right, hold on.
Are you, are you playing music in the background?
Uh, my sister's playing the violin.
Oh, okay.
Um, uh, so you see it.
Did you see the, uh, the statement I was on
Fox news with a guy, the daily wire host,
Michael Knowles talked like read only quarter
mentally ill.
Yes, I did.
And I guess he's kicked off of Fox news now.
Yeah, she, I think was a good move by them,
but it just made me think like, why, why then
did they decide to kick someone off?
Like if you like Laura Ingram still just show
a lot of these people still have [inaudible].
Right.
Even could have been kicked out, kicked out
ago for any number of things that you did.
Yeah, no, I mean, listen, I think it's when
you, when you call
the catalyst,
when you call a kid who's autistic, mentally
ill, that does even there's a line, no matter
where you are, the line is different on Fox
news than elsewhere and it crossed Fox's lines.
So that, but you're completely right.
I mean, arguably when Tucker Carlson said
immigrants make us dirtier and poorer or whatever
[inaudible] he could have been kicked off
for that.
The other thing is Michael knows Knowles was,
is not an employee or, I mean maybe he was
a contributor, which I don't know if that's
an employee or an independent contractor,
but he's not like a host.
So it's also probably a lower bar.
Like you get rid of them.
You sent, if he was a host, maybe he just
gets sent on a mandatory two week vacation
or something.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just, I don't understand why, I think
it'd be interesting if they say brought you
on the show some time with like, who is you?
And Michael and kind dispute disparately funny
to see.
Yeah.
You know, it's funny, I was recently, it was
recently brought to me, um, I recently received
a proposal from my agent about doing something
with Michael Knowles and we both were like,
yeah, there's no upside to this.
Interestingly enough.
You sure?
I mean,
I don't know and maybe maybe you're booking
an appointment.
I used to be a fan of in when I was like on
the right wing.
So I mean, I definitely back that would have
liked to hear your opinion.
So I, for one, I'd love to see you talk to
Michael.
Interesting.
All right, well I'll take that under advisement.
Political now, how long has your sister been
playing violin, Nathan?
Um, she, every, well, all my brothers and
sisters play violin.
We've been playing probably for like 10 years.
Wow.
Okay.
Very good.
Yeah.
All right.
I will let you get back to her practice.
I appreciate the call.
Okay.
I guess Nathan's already gone.
Thank you.